the Wolfenstein series can be called
many things groundbreaking trend-setting
and gleefully gory but mentally taxing
isn't one of them in fact most
installment in this legendary franchise
have been a bit mindless you're a guy
with a gun the game puts Nazis on the
other end of it and you click until they
get dead and move on to the next batch
fortunately Wolfenstein the new order is
doing something different to separate
itself from other shooters and its
predecessors for those of you looking to
change up your approach to FPS games
Wolfenstein is more than happy to
embrace stealth as well as brute force
where stealth and other shooters tends
to be pushed into individual missions or
somewhat disregarded the new order is
doing a good job of incorporating it as
much more than just stealth but stealth
sake the Nazis don't automatically know
where you are which gives you the
opportunity to sneak up behind them for
a silent takedown weapons like the
pistol can also be customized to fit a
silencer if you want to continue this
Delta approach at range on top of that
one of the game's more interesting
features is the inclusion of unlockable
perks and abilities for flexing your
stealth skills including knife throwing
and silent shot which are pretty
self-explanatory another way that the
new order is separating itself from
other shooters is in its level design
unlike some typical FPS levels
Wolfenstein is keeping things
interesting by making it well far more
open and explorable outside of the A to
B paths through the game levels you'll
also be able to find secrets and
alternative words if you choose to look
for them this goes hand-in-hand with the
stealth approach and allows you to turn
a game where you can shoot your way
through with dual machine guns to one
where you can stop think and plan ahead
in what is a welcome change of pace for
games of this genre health doesn't
actually regenerate this means you can
no longer rely on the completely
irrational occurrence of ducking behind
a chest high wall for 15 seconds and
recovering to full health
instead Wolfenstein is bringing on the
med kit which you'll need to be sucking
out in every corner of those big open
levels if you want to stay alive that
and well actually try not to get shot
obviously the Nazis themselves offer a
little reprieve as you can pick up the
armor after you shoot them just make
sure they're actually dead first whilst
good AI in shooters isn't exactly an
unfamiliar thing the new water does a
really good job of implementing the
feature and integrating it into its
contextual hierarchy this one's probably
easier to illustrate than it is to
explain so you're cracking into an
infiltration and trying to keep it
stealthy if you kill an OP the commander
then as a result it will prevent alarms
from being sounded and keep extra Nazi
reinforcements from morning the enemy
hierarchy is an interesting addition
which extends to more than just this
instance and makes your approach to a
level a little more tactically demanding
and you would traditionally expect it to
be whether you're a fan of FPS games or
not it's great to see Wolfenstein the
new order trying to do something
different with similarities and clones
of bounds in the genre and between
modern games it's refreshing to see a
game that's trying to set itself apart
last week on the gist I talked to you
guys about Mario Kart 8 and here's what
you thought the game Bruno BRS wanted to
add I think you should have mentioned
the fact that you can get a second game
for free if you register Mario Kart 8 on
Club Nintendo by July that's a pretty
big incentive to buy one and one that
could be better advertised that is
certainly worth the mention while some
of you were annoyed that this one is
still a wii u exclusive mrgo said when I
saw the Nintendo Direct from Mario Kart
I was suddenly convinced to buy a Wii U
I got the wind waker bundle now and this
console is awesome
the gamepad is much lighter and more
comfortable than I thought as for the
chance to finally show that blue shell
what for me is showing echoed many of
our thoughts by saying I can't wait to
use and
horn item to block a blue shell it will
be the single greatest moment for any
cut veteran years of progress and now
here we are that is it for me today
please continue to leave me your
thoughts in that commenting section down
below and I will see you next week